I'm Harold Varmus I'm a cancer biologist
and I'm the president of Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center I'd like
to talk to you a little bit about how
somebody becomes a scientist many people
think that scientists are born and
they're born with with special
properties they listen to Mozart in the
crib they they excel at math even in
grade school they join the Chess Club
they don't do athletics they they end up
being victors and science fairs before
they get to college and they enter a
track that leads to advanced degrees in
science and engineering and of course
this sometimes happens and reinforces
the popular image but there are lots of
ways to become a scientist and it's
important at a time when the u.s. is
losing numbers of scientists and not
training enough to sustain our
leadership and industry and and and the
sciences to think about other ways in
which people do become scientists I had
myself an unusual route to being a
scientist I'd like to spend a little bit
of time telling you about what that
route was like so I was a good but not
exceptional student in public high
schools in Freeport New York on Long
Island I didn't have strong science
teachers I didn't show any particular
interest in science I didn't spend my
afternoons with a chemistry set I've
spent more than playing tennis and going
to the beach or reading novels than I
did attempting to win science fairs my
father was a doctor and I expected to
follow him into medicine and after high
school went off to Amherst College is a
pre-medical student and there at Amherst
placed before me was a very rich table
of intellectual opportunities and
physics and philosophy
literature in history and I found myself
spending most of my time running the
college newspaper and doing a thesis on
Charles Dickens and spending time with
my literary friends I continue to think
about medical school but didn't do
particularly well in chemistry and
decided finally to go off to graduate
school in English literature where I
spent a year before deciding again to
think about medical school and after
being rejected by one Harvard I chose to
go to another Columbia and found myself
engrossed in sequence in psychiatry and
then internal medicine never paying much
attention to serious laboratory research
but interested in other serious forms of
research in the clinic but not really
engaged in any of those forms I did
house staff training and then at the age
of 28 the Vietnam War required that I
make a decision about a way to serve my
country without serving a war I didn't
believe in I was able to do that thanks
to a program that allowed those of us
who were dissenters from the war to work
at the National Institutes of Health and
here for reasons that beyond this
discussion I was plunged into work on
the molecular biology of E coli the way
in which bacteria regulate expression of
a set of genes called the lac operon
this exposed me for the first time to
the excitement of laboratory research I
was a lot older than most students who
write to me today to work on an Intel
project in my laboratory at
sloan-kettering but nevertheless I still
had the same kind of enthusiasm I see in
those high school students for
understanding how a bacterial organism
controls its genes molecular biology was
in its early phases the idea of using
bacteria or other simple organized
as model organisms for understanding
higher levels of regulation in complex
organisms was still again at its early
stages and this was an exhilarating time
but it's not something I had been
trained for and I wanted to get back to
something that was more medically
related which I did when I discovered
through coursework at the NIH that that
there was a new excitement about viruses
very small packets of genes that were
able to turn a normal cell into a cancer
cell cancer was an important and is an
important human disease I was interested
in trying to understand with the new
tools of molecular biology and at that
point the age of 30 I came to the
University of California San Francisco
to begin what proved to be over two
decades of work on how cancer viruses
grow and how they turn a normal cell
into a cancer cell the reason I tell
this story is to illustrate that there
are lots of ways to become a scientist
and that in the u.s. one of the great
advantages we have is that we don't
require that people make career
decisions at an early age we allow we
even encourage what I would call a
prolonged adolescence this is something
to keep in mind as you progress through
high school and college there is still
time to make decisions about the way
you're going to conduct your careers
moreover it's important to remember that
not every scientist is a math whiz as a
grade school student that there are lots
of ways to become a scientist and lots
of ways to be a scientist in fact I
would argue that that while science can
involve experimental procedures and
analysis of classical experiments there
are lots of other ways to think like a
scientist even in fields that are
outside of what we call the conventional
natural sciences so thinking like a
scientist means thinking about evidence
gathering it evaluating it and
interpreting it in a way that helps to
make sense of the world in which we live
we need more of this in our
world and it's with an effort to
understand that there are lots of paths
to developing a scientific outlook that
can influence your career and help
strengthen our society that I offer this
brief story of an unconventional way to
become a scientist
you